yo father the red rocket Shh
[ __ ] Callen it's over Bry you old ass
piece of [ __ ] oh man it's so gonna be
here to thank you for letting me put up
my art do I like how long does it take
you to make six seconds that's how good
is good though bro scribble it out it
looks good you when you turn 18 Rookie
of the Year and I'm glad you here keep a
because we got this little man look at
how tight this is oh my god you earned
it man what you earned it I feel like I
said I want to make a little speech
please do
dude this is uh this is for this for all
the haters out there this for everyone
that said I couldn't do it [ __ ]
you're wrong I proved you wrong again
and again and again and I'm gonna keep
on proving you wrong and I'm taking over
this podcast that's an announcement I
wanted to make to you guys good it's no
longer the fighter and the kid okay the
kid is dead the kid is gone it is
finally the Red Rock forever solid you
broke thank you so much you guys
thank you so much you earned it machine
handmade this huh oh god this is so nice
dad told me that tape that after hours
that these guys may make you make
Samsung phones is that you have to make
a day 35 go kid I Love New York it's a
great city but I don't like how much New
York people brag about their [ __ ]
bagels it's New York bagels everyone's
like obsessive and they like jack and
Brad roads dense bread you made round
and spread and everyone
Pizza talk [ __ ] I'll talk with the pizza
I like la cabeza la competes with Iowa
compete no no no it's just a business
that we have a lot of New York [ __ ] now
okay just so many New York transplants
here great but also by the way that's
the thing about New York you know
there's so many piece of shitty spots in
New York yeah that are like such [ __ ]
that you're like well we don't even eat
that Chad
taursus I got my best slice and you're
like now that is garbage and he knows
pizzas over A's and E's you know Oh
Chicago I went to the three top here
comes the red rocket dude they kind of
let me call you Brian now the red rice
dude that's it Brian here's the problem
Oh easy but easy red no people people
hate on the casserole now I'm looking
for two people first of all dude
deep-dish pizza is its own thing yeah
it's a casserole it's a pie it's a
[ __ ] pot right now what I want yeah
so anyways largest gang peace rally he
was [ __ ] it to go down see if there's
photos of the walk dude it was crazy to
watch people were ripped it ripped no
it's all it was over it was I was on the
internet somewhere but I but I know
about that kodak black going after his
[ __ ] feel that listen this morning i
listened this morning to him kind of
defending what what he said trying to
like give a defense to what he was
saying soon you just he was making a bad
joke he thought he was being back joe
he's a dumbass yeah he's done it also by
the way you know that rowdy and those
two face tattoos the bring up a photo of
just kodak black and i cuz I was gonna
tweet this the other dinner scene his
body just just as his face just his face
let's put an image may be the ugliest
[ __ ] feather I've ever seen in my
life ever
this kid is so goofy looking terrible
looking whoa what a [ __ ] who is
[ __ ] this guy girls if you're you're
[ __ ] the sky are you a little right
yeah a little pride ladies look at that
picture right down there on the red go
to go to the yeah that one that guy so
it's like dog dude its own suck you know
yeah yep yak-yak-yak Yolo pride
[Music]
that's a long I knew it man what's all
your mouths or to solve and hit that
solo what happened oh the mic that
little bit Ellen makes me gay hey you
know you become a great yeah our fine
anyway if you want this I you just
picked up some water with this okay
Rogan I loved it I wanted you to listen
to it yeah
anything you've heard I heard seven days
before yeah yeah I love Kevin so you
know for me I love Kevin I love Kevin
was it I didn't hear the end I loved a
message he gave yeah liked about the
haters and he doesn't listen to that and
just the way he deals with thing my only
critique of it is loved it but I felt
like Kevin went in with an agenda like
had a plan going in which I like I want
to combo of two of the most powerful men
in entertainment Rogan and Kevin like
that we're at a coffee table yeah you
know I think Evans very thought-out God
now in that situation you know that's
what that's my problem
yeah that's my problem
it's not a problem I enjoyed the [ __ ]
Kevin's with my favorite people in the
world yeah and he's a pioneer he's an
absolute legend yeah but I felt like
there was an agenda of things that talk
about have you heard Rhodes say less
words on a podcast ever yeah he might
said seven words yeah it's just Kevin
with and then my supplements bring up my
stuff ones have this this oh I didn't
hear that Marcie I didn't get to that
part yeah you see guys like I'm starting
my own supper why not and then it's this
I was a cop [ __ ] do you know he's
pitching all this and I don't know right
here he's a bit he's a business man yeah
straight businessman so ten one of the
most generous people I've ever seen in
my life generous did you watch a special
I didn't I'm going to I'll see he's a
monster
yeah it's weird because it's filmed in a
in arena his face makes me laugh just he
just makes me laugh yeah they both make
me laugh when you when you stone stories
about [ __ ] uh Patrice O'Neal oh my
god when he just here make me laugh the
Patrice O'Neal Thunder he laughs man we
said he's just not sad without me
through a phone book on stage but that's
better material some of it's not though
I hope so you can see where your own oh
that's not fake yes but she's like Russ
or some [ __ ]
yeah rush ism oh you know what I saw in
Russia and I think it was real
this guy was a prankster [ __ ] the guy
was a prankster and he would he would
get into mailboxes and when you put your
mail in he would push your mail back out
well I've seen that sold and then
there's a giant guy put it in they just
put a gun and pulled out a gun and just
shot it into the [ __ ] mailbox
he just went I'm sure she killed him
and I was here that's the guy dodging I
mean he's just in a mailbox and the guy
just he was so it was like the 90s it
was so clearly a gangster he was so
clearly a giant gangster he discussed he
just goes dish dish dish dish when I
ruined your mail yeah
video clip shows there's this false oh
it is ache well this is a quarter Snopes
all right false good good good
but it's old Kalin yeah a lot of them
are fake a lot of the prank ones
especially ever great super fake well
are you trying to go viral
yeah in Russia when the guy
screaming people don't like that do uh
like that you did the guys start doing
in Russia yeah
Russians were like really every [ __ ]
Russian haven't start punching and
punching kind of well like that have you
still look for my mom bro we've been
nope we've been honest you know what my
mom she her birthday was two weeks ago
yeah he's not what for my birthday is
lunch with Bryan Callen I will give it
to her I mean I meant lunch hi men I'll
give her a good lunch
I'll get on watch your face twitching
for to take it easy look at what are you
feed by mom I'm not like a meatball sub
or something I'll give your mom the
meatball sub if we're gonna take our
time that's fine like that huh okay you
get talking that time yeah it's gonna be
hot sure no problem gonna be I tell my
mom wear a dress it's gonna be long why
okay she likes long hot dinners lunches
and I'm gonna feed it to her no that's
fine it's nice to be fed yeah Maria's
gonna go my bedroom hey sorry I got your
room service
yeah oh that make gnome service okay
yeah you think you're like a turkey
server yeah well I'm gonna I'm gonna be
like it all over my room service
yeah I know but what do you think like
specifically kind of food well I'm
thinking of you some sort of meat yeah
yeah I'm thinking as far as food is
concerned about my American boner it's
my mom do all right I'm gonna suck you
in a phasing if you get if you bring
nubby into this man take it easy
if knobby do you feed uh B if nobody's
there what do you give nubby if watch
your words she's you know I love baby I
don't but you know I have a pen shawl
for the bread yeah sure
like British stuff wants to hang out
yeah what are you a feed uh B I got
stamina my American boner okay you know
what all right man well share stay away
from nubby I can't wait to see her not
be in your mom yeah they they what they
do want to see you I want to see your
boy Jay I want to see clop when you see
my back
I pull myself up like a champ like a
chimp through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a Gish it's a gift it's a gift